uh so this means that the trade will
happen much sooner the trade for the
rook and against porn will happen much
sooner than nakamura would like and uh
magnus he thinks he knows he's winning
but he just put in his head in his hands
to calculate and this is what ivanka
means the white rook wants to slide
across next move white doesn't actually
want to make a queen on the next turn
white's rook is going to slide across
and block the black rook from
sacrificing itself so it has to
sacrifice itself immediately and here we
see the race yes is that black pawn
quick enough nakamura on his camera
thinks not the white rook is gonna stop
that pawn there we go and now the white
king's gonna sprint back towards that
black pawn nakamura resigns his pawn
wouldn't have been in time anyway and
magnus takes the win
it's a win first game for magnus carlsen
against ikaro nakamura great start to
the day for magnus carlsen what a great
uh win as well it took
uh 15 minutes but uh is this like a
classical magnus kind of when you know
the the pawns just racing up there yep
that's why he loves to push his pawns
early in the middle